[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number 91
of the weekly "Google
Cloud Platform Podcast."
I am Francesc Campoy.
And I'm here with my
colleague Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I am
awake and moving.
How are you doing?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I am moving.
But awake part--
I mean, I've had three coffees.
I just came back
from long holidays.
And I'm very, very
highly jet-lagged,
but other than
that, very excited.
Because we have an episode
about some really cool stuff.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We're
going to be talking
about the future of media
with machine learning,
so basically how machine
learning can make media,
like TV, video games, all kind
of streaming, more engaging,
more like just
cooler in general.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And by definition, that's cool.
MARK MANDEL: No,
it is super cool.
Amit Pande is coming
to join us, super
excited to have
him on the podcast.
And then after that,
we have our question
of the week, where
we're actually
going to return to
last week's question--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yup.
MARK MANDEL: --talking about
accessing Kubernetes clusters
from mobile phones.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Because we've
got two people pointing us
to some really cool stuff.
It's a really, really cool way
of accessing your Kubernetes
clusters from mobile.
And we'll discuss that.
It is amazing.
MARK MANDEL: It's
pretty awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, it is very cool.
But before that,
we have, as always,
our cool things other week.
MARK MANDEL: Yup.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And the first one
is about Google
Cloud Speech API.
And there's a bunch of new
things in the latest release.
One of the coolest things is
there's this new feature which
is Word Level Timestamped, which
basically means that now you're
able to know not only what
is said in an audio file,
but also at what point
in that audio file
those words were said.
So basically if you have
something like this podcast
and you send it, now you
could be like, oh, OK,
so at what point did we
actually say podcast?
And you would be
able to say, well,
that was at the beginning,
minute one, and then whatever.
So basically what
I was saying is
that you could use this
to make, like, a karaoke.
MARK MANDEL: You could
automate karaoke.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Automated karaoke.
You could do a podcast karaoke.
Podcastoke?
MARK MANDEL: Podcastoke,
yeah, we should do that.
VC funding, definitely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Another cool thing is
that until now, the audio
files that you were able to
upload were up to 80 minutes.
Now, it's three hours.
And if you want to make
them even longer, you can.
You need to submit
a quota extension,
but it's definitely doable.
And we support a massive
amount of languages.
We added 30 new language
varieties among them.
There has Bengali.
There's Latvian and
Swahili and many others.
So check it out, very,
very excited about it.
I think I'm going to start
playing with Cloud Speech API
again after this.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
For a second cool thing of
the week, possibly less shiny
and pretty, but definitely
probably more practical--
if you're a user
of data flow, we
had started a series back in
June talking about a guide
to common Dataflow
use case patterns,
so doing things like pushing
data to multiple storage
locations, or interacting
with, say, look up
caches, things like that.
There are common patterns.
So we just released the
second part of that.
We'll link to both
of them actually,
where we have a few
more patterns grouping
by multiple data
properties, stream
merge, so like
large lookup tables,
all sorts of other stuff.
So if you work with Dataflow
and you deal with streaming data
and you want to see some
common patterns about how
to solve some common
problems, this series
might well be for you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
It comes with, what
they say, pseudocode.
But it's clearly Java.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
you can definitely
check it out and have a very
good idea on not only what
that pattern looks like, but
actually how to implement it
in your source code if you
decide that's a good one.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
And then finally, it's
another series, actually,
which is super cool, talking
about using Cloud Machine
Learning to build
conversational APIs.
So basically, if you want to
build the sort of chat bots
or things that you can talk to,
which are definitely very cool
right now and very, very--
I don't want to
say the word hip.
I feel old if I say hip.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
It's hip, though.
MARK MANDEL: It is hip looking
at a variety of technologies
from using our Cloud
Speech API, Translate APIs.
And now with part two
of this blog series,
we look at how you can integrate
Cloud Functions into this
to be able to provide some logic
as well into what's going on.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
There's also a little video
that I'll watch later.
Because it shows how
to build the chat bot
that sees, listens, and
talks, and translates Chinese.
And I'm learning Mandarin, so it
looks like an interesting thing
to do.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
that way maybe I'll
be able to fake it like
I actually speak it.
MARK MANDEL: You just need a
little, one of those things,
in your ear and one of these.
And then as people talk to you--
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
It's the future.
MARK MANDEL: It translates in
real time, like "Star Trek."
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Anyway, I think
that that's enough cool things
of the week for today.
MARK MANDEL: Yup.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So let's
go and talk to Amit Pande.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds great to me.
Today, I am excited to have
Amit Pande joining us today,
Product Manager.
Amit, how are you doing today?
AMIT PANDE: I'm doing good.
How are you?
MARK MANDEL: Very, very well.
We're here to talk about
something really cool.
I saw your presentation at
the Cloud Summit in New York
all about machine
learning and broadcasting.
So I really wanted to talk to
you about that on the podcast.
But before we get stuck
into that, why don't you
tell us a little
bit about yourself
and what you do here at Google?
AMIT PANDE: Sure.
I'm Amit Pande.
I'm a Product Manager
on Google Cloud.
My role is to work closely
with leaders across media
and entertainment industry to
help them envision, and then
design and transform
their business with using
Google Cloud, Big Data,
and Machine Learning.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So you said media
and entertainment.
I have heard about DevOps.
But what is media
and entertainment?
What does that entail exactly?
AMIT PANDE: So media
and entertainment
includes products and
solutions for broadcast,
for digital publishing,
for gaming, and then
on the entertainment side, both
production and post-production.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
When you say video game, do you
mean like video game playing
or when people watch
video games or both?
AMIT PANDE: Both.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So let's talk a little bit
more about what this actually
entails related to
Google Cloud Platform.
What does Google Cloud Platform
have to do with this industry?
AMIT PANDE: Yeah.
So let's take an example.
For broadcast industry, we
have a fully managed end
to end service with support
and SLAs all the way
from getting your
live signal to being
able to distribute that live
signal to the end users.
And then being able to
help you better monetize,
we are providing
products and solutions
for each of those steps
in your supply chain.
Similarly, we have
products and solutions
for some of the other verticals
inside media and entertainment.
MARK MANDEL: So what
would that actually look
like from, say, a
customer point of view?
Like say, if I'm watching
TV, I may not notice it.
But what would
be, say, something
that might be happening behind
the scenes to a broadcast
that I might be watching?
AMIT PANDE: So from a
consumer perspective,
all the way from, say, there's
a typical Super Bowl game that
is being broadcasted,
we capture that signal
on the broadcaster's
on site premise,
upload it to Google
Cloud, transcode it
in all the different
versions for you
to be able to consume on your
mobile, on your Apple TV,
on your Roku, on your
connected devices,
and then being
able to distribute
that through Google's
Cloud Distribution network
as well as third party
distribution network,
so that you have a seamless
experience when you're
watching this content online.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So I've been working lately
with a bunch of Go Meetups
to be able to do
live streaming, which
is like YouTube Live
and stuff like that.
So I guess that what
you're talking about
is basically the same
idea of YouTube Live,
but without having
YouTube involved.
So like, the whole
infrastructure
is run by Google.
And you can
[INAUDIBLE] anything?
AMIT PANDE: Yeah, exactly.
So it's, in fact, using
the similar infrastructure
as what YouTube is
using, but providing
that as infrastructure as
a service to third party
broadcasters, like all of the
large TV networks out there.
And it can be used for
streaming live events.
It can be used for just
creating your own live channel
as well as being able to
distribute your video on demand
assets.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
maybe the answer is no.
But can you talk a little
bit about who is doing this?
AMIT PANDE: So we have a lot
of large customers out there.
For example, we had a
very recent presentation
at Google Next in New York.
And Univision was
sharing the stage
with us talking about their
journey of moving from on-prem
to Google Cloud infrastructure.
And we have a lot more customers
that are using our service.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, I guess I'm going to ask
maybe the obvious question.
We are a company that tends to
be known for machine learning
type stuff.
Is this somewhere we also
apply machine learning?
Or are we just in the
streaming business?
AMIT PANDE: No, absolutely.
In fact, when we think about
how machine learning can
help transform your media
and entertainment business,
we think about three buckets.
We think machine learning can
help you innovate and build
those next generation
experiences.
It can help you better
monetize your content.
And it can help you reduce
your operational cost,
while delivering your
content at global scale.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: How?
MARK MANDEL: I was going
to say, you say innovate.
What does that mean?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
AMIT PANDE: Yeah.
So let's take a
typical supply chain
for content business
[INAUDIBLE]..
Let's take the creative
process of content creation.
We can apply machine learning to
help you determine exact clips
and automatically
generate highlights
for your content using
machine learning.
Let's take another example.
Content recommendation has been
around for a very long time.
And traditionally,
content recommendation
was based on content metadata.
We can use machine learning
to actually understand
what's happening
inside your video
and help you find
visually similar videos
that you can recommend.
So it can be another signal
that can feed into your content
recommendation system.
Another example is
machine learning
can automatically
microsegment your content
and analyze and draw
insights each of the segments
of your content.
If you had a TV
show and you wanted
to understand which actors
are drawing more audience
or which scenes are
seeing higher engagement,
with machine learning
now you have the ability
to both combine your audience
retention data and the deeper
segmentation of your content
to draw these kind of insights.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: This
made me think about that--
I think it was IBM.
They did this research where
they created a movie trailer
from movie directly using AI.
Is this the kind of thing
we're talking about?
AMIT PANDE: Yeah, absolutely.
All the way from being
able to create trailers
to being able to create
automatic highlights
or previous, correct?
So let's take an example
for you're probably
familiar with the "Chopped"
cooking game show.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
AMIT PANDE: And [INAUDIBLE]
can combine all of the signals,
correct?
Like it can automatically
segment your video.
It can annotate each of the
segments inside your video,
rank the segments based on
your audience engagement data.
And it can help identify things
like, where is the start,
where is the middle and end?
And not only that,
it can also start
looking at background,
audio, to understand
where those interesting moments
are happening inside your game
show.
And then using all of this--
like as a user, if you come in
and it's like, I only
have three minutes.
And I want a quick highlight.
We can generate that
highlight on demand, correct?
So it's almost helping
you consume your content
on demand based on
your requirements
Similarly for the
games, correct?
Like, you might be--
there's a game yesterday.
And I want to see a highlight
for yesterday's game
for this particular
player, correct?
MARK MANDEL: So I'm curious.
So the stuff you're
kind of talking about
seems to be sort of possibly
like after the fact,
or post-processing.
Is there stuff that
we apply that happens
during a live stream that can
interact or change maybe, I
don't know, camera direction?
Or I don't know, is there crazy
stuff that can happen in-flow?
AMIT PANDE: Yeah.
There is also applications
through machine learning
where I have seen
people using machine
learning to be able to
use one camera to record
an entire game.
So this is actually on
the content creation side,
where they are following
the activity on the field
to understand wherever
the activity is here,
they're actually moving
the camera itself to be
able to follow that activity.
So that's an example
where that is actually
happening on the creation side.
You can imagine as
viewers are watching,
they may be like, I
want to be able to view
this particular player's
perspective on the field.
And every person would want
a different one, correct?
Again, machine learning can
help identify as well as
help you generate that
personalized stream,
so that you can
connect with the users.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
I guess that that is
pretty hard In Real Life, IRL.
AMIT PANDE: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So out of the things that
you were talking about,
specifically about
the part where
you were able to
understand the video
and then create maybe like
highlights or whatever,
that sounds a lot like
the kind of machine
learning skills that Vision
Intelligence API has, right?
So I feel like that moves
a little bit into, OK,
so that sounds really fun.
How do I do it as a developer?
What are the different APIs
or the different products
that I can use in order to
create such an experience?
AMIT PANDE: Yeah.
So on the machine
learning side, actually we
have a full spectrum.
We have TensorFlow for you to be
able to build your own models.
We also have Google Cloud
Machine Learning Engine,
which is a managed
end to end service
that you can use to analyze your
data and build your own models.
And then we have
readily available APIs
which are trained
on Google's data
that you can use to integrate
into your application,
so all the way from natural
language understanding APIs
to converting your speech
to text to translating
text and also, most
importantly for media,
understanding your
images and videos.
So specifically,
we have two APIs.
One is our Google
Cloud Vision API
that helps you understand
structural entities
inside your images and
Google Cloud Video API, which
helps you take a video,
segment it into shots,
and detect labels in the shots.
That can then be used for things
like search and recommendations
and, ultimately, for
generating things
like highlights
or driving better
monetization of your content.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
For those that are curious,
I like to do back references
to other episodes.
We did an episode on TensorFlow,
episode 31 with Eli Bixby.
We did an episode on Cloud
Machine Learning Engine,
episode 71 with Yufeng
Guo, and also an episode
with Sara Robinson about
Cloud Video Intelligence API.
So if you want to know more
about these APIs, check it out.
MARK MANDEL: So I'll ask an
interesting question, too.
So I mean, this all
sounds super, super cool
and crazy and wonderful.
Does this mean that
using this technology,
like we're removing humans
from the application?
Or like is this replacing that?
Or is this a tool that people
can use in conjunction?
Or how do you see this fitting
in the wider spectrum there?
AMIT PANDE: I think
from my perspective
when I think about machine
learning, a very good example
is self-driving cars, correct?
Like we want to get to that
autonomous driving cars.
And we are probably five
years out from that.
But meanwhile, we are
building out these steps
towards having a fully
autonomous car which
are, today, assistive steps.
So similarly, when I think
of about machine learning,
it's starting in
that assistive step.
And then gradually, it's
going to learn and learn,
so that it gets better.
And probably at
some stage, it'll
fully automate the steps
that it's being applied to.
I also feel over time the
way we do our processes,
they will change.
And you'll probably
be able to do it
more efficiently at lower cost.
You'll probably be able
to delight your customers
with better experiences.
And the roles of
humans will change
from doing repetitive tasks
to actually analyzing the data
and using the machines
more intelligently to be
able to perform the tasks.
MARK MANDEL: So
if you're looking
at something like
speech to text,
like doing closed
captioning, you
might use something
like speech to text API.
But then the human might be
just verifying and making sure
that's all correct,
something like that.
AMIT PANDE: Yeah.
That's actually a
very good point.
So I believe because where
the technology is right now,
a lot of these technologies
will benefit when you combine
machine learning with humans.
So if you take the
output of speech to text
and combine it with an edit
tool where you can both quickly
review and edit and
any changes you make,
those actually feed back into
the machine learning model.
It will significantly
improve the precision
and recall that you see for
a future result of that API.
So I think that's one of the
key areas I want to highlight.
As you're thinking about
using machine learning,
always think about how
can I train the models
on context specific data.
And how can I use a
feedback mechanism
to further improve the
precision and recall
of the machine learning APIs
or the results of my machine
learning model?
MARK MANDEL: Are their
feedback mechanisms
for something like text to
speech or Cloud Vision API?
AMIT PANDE: So right now, the
public APIs don't allow that.
But you can imagine
building your own custom
model that further allows
you to feed that back.
And we are looking at
options for enabling, so
that we can continue to help
you improve your quality.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm thinking
that we should try, as a demo,
to do it on our own transcripts.
MARK MANDEL: We should.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
that would be fun.
MARK MANDEL: So we
could actually do it.
So we automate our transcripts
through a third party service.
And then we could do
it through Speech API
and compare the result.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And compare, yeah.
That would be
really interesting.
AMIT PANDE: We also have a
practical application, correct?
YouTube also allows you
to automatically generate
closed captions.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, yes.
That works super well.
AMIT PANDE: And it's
similar technology
that we're bringing to Google
Cloud as part of the APIs,
correct?
So all that data
we're just training
is going to help power the
APIs that you're using.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I
publish a bunch of videos.
I have a YouTube channel.
And one of the coolest
things of posting on YouTube
is that you get the closed
caption, and then also
the automatic translations
to a bunch of languages--
AMIT PANDE: Exactly.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --which
is very useful for people
that do not understand English.
Is that something that we can
do real time on a live stream,
for instance?
Or are we still not there?
AMIT PANDE: I think right now,
we're obviously not there.
But I do foresee that in
the next 6 to 12 months,
the technology
will get to a point
where we will start
applying this to real time.
There are some tricks
available where
you can pre-train your
models on context specific.
Like, for instance, if you
have a sporting game which
is where you probably care
about being real time,
you can train the model
specifically for that context.
And then the real
time output would
be pretty good in terms of
quality here at the level
that that is acceptable from a
closed captioning [INAUDIBLE]..
So there are some tricks
available to being
able to apply
almost in real time
and getting the results
to the quality level
that that matches
your expectation.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So we've been
talking a little bit
about how to make the
broadcasting experience
and the process itself
more pleasant, I'd say,
or more automated,
better experience.
But you also mention
monetization, money.
I like that.
How do you apply machine
learning for profit?
How do you make
money out of this?
AMIT PANDE: Yeah.
So one of the things
machine learning can do
is it can understand your video.
And it can help you find
those specific moments
in the video where there
are commercial intents.
So it can annotate it with
products and labels and brands
that the users are talking
about in your video itself.
And it can also help you figure
out exactly how many ads should
you show.
So today, in most cases, if
you're watching a content,
you probably have a
pre-determined number of ads,
like maybe three ads or four
ads that you've come up with.
And generally, that is
a client-side logic.
We can combine that
with service-side logic
and a learning algorithm which
says for this particular user,
if I show a fourth ad,
he will likely drop off.
But for this, another
user maybe showing two ads
is that optimal number.
And the duration of those
ads as well, correct?
Like we've already starting
to see the 30 second ads.
There's huge buzz in the
industry on bumper ads,
the 6 second ads, correct?
What is the right length
of that ad of the user?
And that can be personalized.
So the ad itself
being shown based
on the content, the
number of ads being shown,
and the length of the
ads itself, each of those
we can innovate using
machine learning.
For instance, you could show
like a brand ad, correct?
And when shown at
the right moment,
there's clear data
in the industry that
shows they will perform
significantly better
than showing regular ads.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I'm
imagining that for instance we
have AdSense, right?
And AdSense, basically
what it does,
is when you add it to
web page, according
to the content of
the web page, it
shows you ads that
are related to it.
Because if you're reading
that, probably you're
interested in those things.
Is that what you're saying?
That if I'm watching TV--
I'm watching, I don't
know, like "Modern Family."
And at some point, I see a car.
And then they're going to
be like, oh, by the way,
you can buy this car here.
AMIT PANDE: Exactly, correct.
So you might be watching
a Travel Channel.
And it's talking about
this destination.
And you see an ad
right at that moment
from your current destination
to being able to travel
to this destination.
There are flight tickets
available for XX price.
You're likely to convert on that
versus a completely random ad
being shown at that market.
MARK MANDEL: Could you also
customize the ad as well,
like change how the
ad experience is
for that customer on the fly
and do fun stuff that way, too?
AMIT PANDE: Yeah.
That's exactly some of the
very exciting stuff when
I was talking about
earlier in terms
of applying machine learning
to the creative process.
You can think about all this
analysis that we're drawing
and on the fly being
able to generate
these dynamic creatives, which
are personalized to the user.
And in fact, I believe
there's this next wave that
is going to happen
to ad creatives
where instead of just creating
a small number of video ad
creatives that target
100% of the users,
you will generate a
lot more of those.
And then with machine learning,
you will be able to slice
and connect it with the right
users at the right moment.
And there's interesting
stuff happening in this space
all the way from being able to
take your base video creative,
and then overlaying with
context specific personalized
information, like that the
travel example I gave you
to products being overlaid,
and then connecting
those with the user.
So again, a very exciting space.
And I think machine
learning is definitely
going to transform
the way we watch
ads, and the number of ads,
and the quality of the ads
that we view.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I have a
completely ridiculous question.
So I was thinking about
how machine learning is
getting to a point
where it's also
able to generate new content.
Like DDReam is a very cool
example, where you give it
an image, and it creates
something surrealistic,
like super cool ads
and stuff like that.
Do you think that in, I don't
know, like 10 to 20 years,
we'll be able to see
videos generated directly
completely by machine learning?
AMIT PANDE: I think over time
we will build probably maybe
in five to seven years.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh,
wow, five to seven.
Wow.
AMIT PANDE: This is probably
the self-driving car space,
where I think the step
one in that process
is going to use data to assist
with the creative process
of content creation.
And then over time,
you can imagine.
Say you have raw
footage of whatever,
30 hours of raw footage.
A very good example, which
makes us a little [INAUDIBLE]
is reality TV show, correct?
We have like 10 cameras and
24 by 7 shooting, correct?
So there's a lot of content.
You need to condense
it down to like
30 minutes or 40 minutes of
what people are going to watch.
And there is no perfect answer
of what's right there, correct?
And you can imagine
machine learning kind
of combining and learning
from user preferences
and taste to
actually finding out
these are the actors
your interested in.
These are the kind of semantic
moments that appeal to you,
and using that to
take your raw footage
and summarizing it down to 30
minutes that you're interested.
So that's the extreme
example, correct?
Obviously, would it be able to
generate this perfect episode
of "House of Cards? for me?
I mean, we are definitely
far from that, correct?
But you can start
thinking about applying it
to things like ad creatives,
and then maybe taking
content where it's already
being stitched together.
There's a lot of
raw footage that you
need to condense down to.
Maybe games is
another example where
you want to see a personalized
version of the game, where
you're like, I'm
interested in touchdowns.
And I'm interested in
this player, correct?
You can codify the
user intentions.
That's probably the start
of this creative process.
And then over time, I
think there will be more
of this data being available.
And as we learn, we'll
be able to apply that
to more and more content types.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
MARK MANDEL: I mean,
we already see that now
in the consumer space.
I mean, I get notifications
from Google Photos saying, hey,
we saw that you
were in this place.
And here's a montage of
the thing you were seeing.
Or like--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: --you
could so similar things
with home videos,
that kind of stuff.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And those tend
to be actually pretty good.
MARK MANDEL: They're
usually really good, yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, that's right.
AMIT PANDE: And exactly.
That is the same technology
that I'm talking about.
Like Google has state
of the art content
summarization,
ability to understand
those interesting moments.
And we can start building
more of these models
based on user
preferences and tastes
for you to really be able
to innovate in the space.
MARK MANDEL: So this
all sounds awesome.
If people want to
learn more about this--
obviously, we've talked about
sort of the Cloud Vision
API, the text to speech.
Is there anything
around learning
how to apply TensorFlow
to video or anything
like that you would
recommend as a resource
that people could
potentially go to?
AMIT PANDE: So I
think the best bet
is to be able to follow the
TensorFlow documentation.
And then on the API
side, definitely
look at the Cloud Vision and
the Cloud Video Intelligence API
to get you started.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I also
would recommend something.
We talked about Kaggle.
And I think that if you want to
do like TensorFlow with video,
Kaggle had these
YouTube 8 million
contest, which it's
an amazing data set.
So that would be a
good place to start.
AMIT PANDE: Yeah,
that's absolutely right.
Being able to have that huge
amount of data set to be
able to train will be huge.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And it's there.
MARK MANDEL: It's
there, and it's free.
AMIT PANDE: Have fun, yup.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Awesome.
All right, well, we are
running out of time.
So is there anything else you
want to make sure you mention,
any events or anything you
want to plug before we wrap up
the episode today?
AMIT PANDE: Yeah.
So if you are in
Europe, we are going
to be at IBC in
mid-September in Amsterdam.
So please feel free
to join our booth.
I'm going to be there, so
happy to answer any questions.
We also have another
event happening
in Los Angeles in
late September,
which is focused on machine
learning and content creation.
If you're interested,
please reach out to me.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Awesome.
MARK MANDEL: Well,
Amit, thank you
so much for coming and joining
us on the podcast today.
AMIT PANDE: Thank
you, everybody.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thanks
so much to Amit Pande
for such an
interesting interview.
I did not know that you could
do so many cool things, like not
only automating things
with machine learning,
but actually making the content
you're creating even more
engaging.
Super cool.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, no.
I super love this.
I think this is a really
exciting time for broadcast
across a variety of
platforms, across sports,
e-sports, even live television.
Like, there's so much cool
stuff that could happen here.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: When
you say e-sports,
it's like video games, right?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK, cool.
MARK MANDEL: Everything from
me comes back to video games.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
E-sports, I like it.
I do e-sports, too.
I play "Zelda."
Cool.
MARK MANDEL: That's not
quite right, but it's fine.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I do not care.
That is my opinion.
OK.
So let's go with our
question of the week.
So our question of
the week this week
comes from actually last week.
It comes from
Itamar [INAUDIBLE]..
And I might be
mispronouncing the name.
I'm sorry for that.
But he asked us last week how
to access a Kubernetes cluster
from a mobile phone
while he's on the go.
And we said that
there was, you know,
like a bunch of different
ways of doing it.
But none of them was actually
that convincing, that good.
And we said, you know, it's a
pity that there's no better way
to do it.
But it turns out we have
a very engaged audience.
And they were like,
actually, there
is an amazing way of doing it.
And we're going to be
talking about that today.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So we got a tweet, which
was awesome, from someone
named Dylan Graham.
Dylan, hi.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: At
plusplusdylan on Twitter.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you, Dylan.
Yeah, thank you so much
for sending this in.
This is super, super cool.
So there's an open
source project
from Bitnami called Cabin.
And it is an open
source mobile app
that works on both
Android and iOS
for directly integrating
with Kubernetes.
And it's, like,
really impressive.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It is.
Yeah.
So before we started
recording the episode,
I showed a screencast of what
you can do with the iOS app.
I'm sure that the Android does
pretty much exactly the same.
MARK MANDEL: It's the same app.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
yeah, it blew our minds.
Because you can do
basically everything
you can do with
kubectl, but easier.
MARK MANDEL: It was cool.
Look, OK, so you've got
a bunch of stuff you
can do in there from actually
creating clusters to pod views,
pod logs, doing deployments,
using name spaces.
But I think my favorite part was
he deploys Ghost to Kubernetes
on the screencast and
just adds a deployment
and clicks it through.
And then he's like,
I'm going to scale it.
And he has a slider.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: And he goes
from one pod all the way up
to, like, seven.
He's like, look, I just slide
and apply, and boom and done.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: I was like,
that's actually kind of sick.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And then in order
to expose that service to
the world, he's like, oh,
so I just need to click here
to make it load balancer now,
and done.
MARK MANDEL: Done.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
It's very, very good.
And on top of that, you
can also use hand charts.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I don't know.
I think it's pretty amazing.
I mean, I'm going to
solid, that's for sure.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But I wonder
if it's almost better than just
using kubectl.
You
MARK MANDEL: Maybe
for some things.
It depends what you're doing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
It's just very, very, very nice.
MARK MANDEL: And what
I liked about it, too,
so it's a re-act native app.
So if you want to actually
get in and be involved
with the project and
try and tweak some stuff
or fix some bugs or build
new features, of you
know JavaScript, you
can get in there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
It is open source.
We'll have a link
on this show notes
to both iOS and Android apps
and also the GitHub repo.
Definitely check it out.
It is version 0.3.something.
So it is still not
stable version.
But I'd say it's
definitely worth trying.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, absolutely.
Even if it's just to
be like, oh, let's
see what's happening in my
pod and look at the logs.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Even if you were to
just like view only,
it would be useful enough.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
But on top of that,
you can do a lot of editing
and creating stuff, so amazing.
So, yeah, thanks
Dylan for the link.
And also, thanks to the Bitnami
team for such a cool app,
because it's
really, really cool.
MARK MANDEL: It's
Awesome Well, before
we run away, Francesc,
I know you just got
back from vacation.
So I'm sure you've got
everything planned out.
Where are you going to be?
What are you up to?
What's going on?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
I'm actually going
to be traveling not in
August, but in September.
I will be going to Cloud
Summit in this place
in the little country
called Australia.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yup.
I'm going to Sydney to
talk to the Cloud Summit
about how to build bots
on Google Cloud Platform.
It's going to be lots of fun.
And then after
that in October, I
will be speaking
at Velocity London.
And then in November,
I'll be speaking
at dotGo, which is in
Paris, and then the week
after in GopherCon
Brazil, which is
in Brazil as the name implies.
Yeah, lots of traveling.
Very excited about it.
What about you?
MARK MANDEL: So my month
of crazy is continuing.
So next week, I will
be speaking at PAX Dev,
and then attending
PAX right after that.
Practically a week after
that, I will be in Gameacon
in Las Vegas
speaking, again, there
talking about open source and
Kubernetes and game servers.
And then pretty match the
week or two after that,
I will be at Austin Game
Conference in Austin
doing the same talk yet again.
And then after that, it's
more of a conference for me.
I will be attending
Strange Loop,
because I love that place.
It is one of my favorite
places in the world.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I know.
I want to go there, too.
But I cannot this year.
Next year for sure.
MARK MANDEL: You
say that every year.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I know.
I'm awful.
Anyway, thanks, Mark,
for taking the time today
to talk about the
future of media
and also a bunch of
cool things of the week
and that amazing
app, very, very cool.
I've already installed
it in my phone.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
And thank you everyone
for listening.
And we'll see you all next week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: See
you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]